ist Armin Laschet ist der nächste Redner
ist auch Vorsitzender der
deutsch-französischen
Parlamentariergruppe
ja vielen Dank herr Präsident ich möchte
an das anknüpfen was der Kollege
alhalak gerade hier beschrieben hat das
Thema lautet Unruhen in Frankreich also
sie haben das Wort Frankreich so gut wie
nicht in den Mund genommen sie sind
nahtlos übergegangen zu ihrer sehr wohl
zugehört ich habe gehört dass hier
gedroht wurde das aufgeräumt wurde wenn
sie an die Macht kommen wir sagen Ihnen
wir werden dafür sorgen dass sie
verkauft haben das können Sie sich
merken
also ich habe sehr wohl zugehört über
Frankreich wurde hier nicht gesprochen
über die Herkunft des Problems haben sie
nicht gesprochen sondern sie haben
gleich über Parallelgesellschaft in
Deutschland geschworen und in der Tat da
haben Sie Recht das war eine
Parallelgesellschaft der NSU der 10
Jahre Morden durchs Land zog die Lübcke
das möchten Sie nicht gerne hören aber
ihre Gesinnungsgenossen haben Menschen
ermordet in diesem Land das war eine
parallele Gesellschaft
und deshalb ist die Kernfrage das habe
ich die Kernfrage wie kann man den
begegnen wie kann man dem begegnen was
muss man tun um Gewalt zu bekämpfen und
da war auch spürbar besonders bei dem
ersten AFD Redner dass sie eigentlich
die Erfolge von Integrationspolitik gar
nicht kennen sie haben das abgetan mit
die Probleme werden mit die Probleme
werden
die Probleme
und sie Herzprobleme oder
können Sie kurz das Anwältinnen sie
haben gesagt das Problem wird mit Geld
zugeschüttet das heißt er hat überhaupt
nicht verstanden dass die die in
Frankreich in den borniers Leben zum
Teil Angehörige der französischen
Kolonialmacht die auf der Seite
Frankreichs gekämpft haben und den in
Frankreich dann ermöglicht hat nach
Paris einzuwandern der große Fehler war
man hat sie in Mons untergebracht sie
hatten kaum eine Aufstiegschance in der
französischen Gesellschaft und die
Präsidenten Frankreichs haben nach 2005
erkannt dass man je mehr Geld nehmen
muss für Bildung für Aufstiegschancen
für bessere Stadtviertel mit dem Abriss
von manchen Hochhäusern um das Viertel
anders zu gestalten und genau das wollen
sie nicht sie wollen nicht dass die
Menschen in der Gesellschaft integriert
sind und deshalb sagen sie die wurden
die wurden quasi mit Geld zugeschüttet
und deshalb hat auch ihre partnerpartei
Frauen national in Frankreich im
Parlament gesagt
ausländische Straftäter ausweisen und
dann ist der französische Innenminister
entgegnet 90 Prozent der Festgenommenen
sind Franzosen es geht hier um
kriminelle Jugendliche und nicht um
Ausländer sie sprechen Französisch sie
haben es geht doch nicht um Kultur und
deshalb ist das viel zu simpel die
Gesellschaft zu spalten und ich trage
ihnen Redezeit ist ja hier sehr kurz
könnte man lange fortsetzen ein paar
Zeilen vor
von der Großmutter des getöteten
Jugendlichen diese Frau hat gesagt hört
auf mit den Krawallen alle die dabei
sind Dinge zu zerstören sage ich hört
auf sie sollen keine Schaufenster
einschlagen keine Schulen zerstören
keine Autobusse es sind Mütter die die
Busse nehmen es sind Mütter die auf den
Straßen unterwegs sind eine mutige Frau
die gerade ihren Enkel verloren hat
sagte das das hat mich erinnert das hat
mich erinnert
das hat mich erinnert an der Flüge
Gensch der Flüge Gensch wird das Opfer
eines
Brandanschlags von Rechtsradikalen
fünf Angehörige sterben es drohen
Unruhen damals in Deutschland und sie
ruft am nächsten Tag zur Versöhnung aus
und sagt das waren nicht die deutschen
das waren vier Straftäter die bestraft
werden müssen etwas von diesem Großmut
der Großmutter aus Frankreich und von
mehrflüge Gensch den wünsche ich Ihnen
in Ihrer Sprache und in ihrem Umgang mit
der Not von Menschen etwas von dem
großen
Armin Laschet bekommt ihr
fraktionsübergreifend Applaus für seine
Rede
[Applaus]